Remember that our program is mostly supported
by individual memberships, which you can find
it, join Pacman dot com and for the next six
days only you can use the coupon code 20-20
now to get 66 percent off of the membership
of your choice at join Pacman dot com.
I want to be really clear as I talk about
this next story of the most important part
of this election is removing Donald Trump
and replacing him with Joe Biden so that we
can start to get the country back on the right
path.
The country has been taken over by lunatic
extremists and ignorant clowns in Washington,
D.C., corrupt fools and delusional narcissists.
This is not about even Republicans and Democrats.
I'll be having a conversation today with the
conservative Douglas Murray about actual conservatism.
This is something very different.
This has been a coup of incompetence, which
must be remedied.
It's dangerous.
It's creepy.
It's disgusting.
It has to be fixed for the sake of all of
our futures.
But in addition to that.
Watching Donald Trump, increasingly triggered
by former President Barack Obama's speeches
has really been a delight.
Last week, Barack Obama rallied for Joe Biden
in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Over the weekend, Barack Obama rallied for
Joe Biden in Miami, Florida.
And every time Trump starts tweeting conspiracies
about Barack Obama attacks on Barack Obama
because he's just so jealous of Barack Obama.
And yesterday, Barack Obama was in Orlando,
Florida, for Joe Biden.
And again, just hammering Trump in exactly
the way that most gets to Trump.
And Trump's insecurities.
I really think Obama is going to make Trump
explode by Election Day at this rate.
Check this out here.
Is Barack Obama going right after Trump on
something Trump is very insecure about, which
is the size of Trump's crowds, which is, of
course, so meaningless.
But it just goes to the heart of Donald Trump's
narcissism, many interest in doing the work
or helping anybody but himself and his friends
or treating the presidency as anything more
than a reality show that can give him the
attention that he craves.
And he does crave attention.
This week, with all everything that's happening,
you know what he brought up?
He was fussing about the crowd size at the
inauguration, again, saying his was bigger.
Who?
Who is thinking about that right now?
No, but it's up to him.
Another theme is that Trump either tries to
undo what Barack Obama did or tries to take
credit for it.
It's one or the other either undo it or claim
that you actually did it.
And again, Barack Obama going right to the
heart of that by talking about jobs numbers,
which did slow down when Donald Trump became
president of the United States.
That complicated.
Donald Trump likes to claim he built this
economy.
But I just want to remind you that America
created one point five million more jobs in
the last three years, that the Obama Biden
administration than in the first three years
of the Trump administration.
That's a fact.
Look it up.
It is a fact.
And I do encourage you to look it up.
And, of course, any reasonable person understands
that there is much more complexity than merely.
Obama was better at job creation than Trump.
But it is true.
Those are the numbers.
And Donald Trump can't handle that.
And he hates that.
And he lies about it.
And then this is just great.
Barack Obama addressing Donald Trump's claim
that he's been the best president for black
people since Abraham Lincoln, even better
than the actual black president.
Take a look at this.
He wants to take credit for it, says he's
the best president for black folks since Abe
Lincoln.
Man now is his rather safe, including his
son in law.
Son in law says white folks have to want to
be successful.
That's the problem.
Who are these folks?
What history books do they read?
Who do they talk to?
Don't read.
Is that what is going on?
And what wild times we live in.
And then lastly here, Barack Obama going after
Donald Trump for being enamored with global
dictators and authoritarians, saying, of course,
they want Trump to win.
And over Donald Trump being so triggered by
Leslie Stall from his 60 Minutes interview,
our current president, he warns that 60 Minutes
is too tough.
You think he's going to stand up to dictators?
He thinks Leslie Stahl is a bully.
Just yesterday, just yesterday, he said that
Putin of Russia, Xi of China and Kim Jong
un of North Korea want him to win.
We know.
We know because you've been giving them whatever
you want for the last four years, of course,
they want you to win.
That's not a good thing.
We'll talk a little bit more about Leslie
Stahl momentarily, but really just finely
tuned to get to Donald Trump and to throw
Trump off balance.
And of course, these are not highly substantive
policy rallies that Barack Obama is doing,
although they have more substance than Trump's,
but they don't have to be.
This is Barack Obama.
This isn't the candidate.
This is a surrogate, in this case, a surrogate
for Joe Biden, who's going out as a popular
person within the party to fire up the base
and really hitting the right notes to trigger
Donald Trump.
And boy, has it worked.
Now, a mite childish for thoroughly enjoying
when Barack Obama does this, Amaia.
Is it infantile for me to relish Obama taking
the gloves off and taking these shots at Trump?
Because it angers Trump more than anything,
I care about policy.
And we've taken Biden's policy on taxes and
done a deep dove as economic policy, energy
policy, climate policy, the whole thing.
And that really matters.
But isn't this great in some way?
And importantly, a really important message
on voting from Barack Obama yesterday.
And this is why I think it's great for him
to be doing these rallies at all.
Barack Obama said we can't be complacent.
We were complacent last time and look what
happened.
And by the way, I think he should also be
saying those people on the.
I know he won't say it.
I say it.
The people on the left who said Hillary Trump,
it's all the same.
They're both neo liberal shills are tools
of the establishment.
Look at the Supreme Court.
My friends look at the Supreme Court.
And the real key here is, as Barack Obama
says, no complacency.
Six days to go.
The latest numbers on early and mail in voting.
As of this morning, 71 million early votes
have been cast.
That's more than half of the total number
of votes in 2016.
Of the 71 million, 48 million roughly have
been Meilin.
The rest have been in-person.
Now, of those 48 percent of of early votes
are Democrats, 29 percent are Republicans.
You might see that and say beautiful.
Joe Biden's got this.
Remember?
Of those polled who have not yet voted overwhelmingly,
they support Trump.
So we have to understand a lot of the early
vote seems to be going for Biden.
Those waiting to vote on Election Day seem
to be leaning Trump.
It is not going to be the blowout that these
early numbers suggest.
We all must vote.
Texas is really voting.
Eighty seven percent of the total 2016 turnout
has already been cast in Texas, very much
suggesting blow it out of the water.
Record turnout in Texas.
And I look forward to seeing those numbers.